sarah had been out with a friend
and gone to their house
the other side of clapham common
and left there about nine o'clock that
night
and then as she walks the two and a half
miles home
for 14 minutes
we understand that she's on earth on her
phone to her boyfriend
and then once that phone call finishes
she's got headphones and she's just
walking home towards her house in tulsa
hill and was this the most direct route
for her yes she's got to come across
clapham common it would have been dark
that night
so
perhaps sticking to the roads
all cutting across the comments she
thought it was quicker
and then she gets into
the main cavendish road into pointers
road
which is the most direct route and well
lit for her yeah this is an arterial
road isn't it the south circular if i
was a single woman walking at night in
the dark i'd probably choose this kind
of route that might offer some kind of
safety i think you would and i think
even as a man you think it's the most
safest route to come home it's well lit
with street lighting and plenty of
properties around so yes i think that's
the route that she would have taken in
every time she went to see her friend do
you have any idea why she wouldn't have
taken a cab
home
the investigation identified
as we can hear that sarah was very
active
probably just walking home at night and
he got to think at the time in on march
the 3rd when she went missing there were
quite severe covert restrictions in
place in london and not many people were
out and about in fact you weren't really
supposed to be out and you weren't
supposed to be visiting friends either
so
that was
um something that she just thought maybe
getting some fresh air so
but no one knows apart from sarah yes i
mean at that time in lockdown
we all were allowed to walk
and maybe she saw this as her exercise
for the day i mean you don't know that
and i think we were limited on when you
could walk and how many times so he has
taken the opportunity to walk home
something she's probably done many many
times with from her friend's house
it's not uncommon to her and it's she
doesn't feel it's going to be
particularly
a problem for her how far was she from
her home at this point so when she
leaves her friend's house she's about
two and a half miles from her from her
own home
from here probably about another mile or
so to go
outside poinders court
when she was approaching this part of
the road what was wayne cousins doing
well we know before she approached here
the investigation identified that
she had been seen walking in this
direction
and then
what you would do is try and find out
how far she's gone after that point and
the investigation team at that time
identified that she hadn't gone any
further than essentially where we are
now
and it took a few days for some bus cctv
to come in to actually find and see
sarah
literally just here with wayne cousins
and the car that he had hired
now until you've got that kind of
evidence she had simply vanished
yes i mean it was a missing person's
inquiry for
a couple of days and because of the
nature of uh sarah and this the
completely out of character for her the
metropolitan police decision to bring in
their homicide teams specialist crime
teams and all the
assets they have with them to to assist
the missing persons inquiry but it soon
became apparent that something had
happened completely out of character and
there was a real concern for sarah so
what was wayne cousins up to that night
so wayne cousins had no reason to be
here at all and i think that was the
thing that everybody identified quite
quickly
he was a serving police officer at the
time hadn't been in the metropolitan
police very long
and he was off duty off duty lives in uh
kent in dover had no reason to be here
this is probably one of those routes
that
he would have taken to go to work
from out in dover into central london
where he was based so he knew the area
he knows the area he knows the roads but
had no reason whatsoever and it's clear
isn't it that the only reason he was
here was to abduct
a woman so he was parked up can you just
describe
what was happening with him and his
vehicle
so when he was originally first seen was
when he was standing next to sarah just
further up the road here
the higher car the white voxel astra
that he hired was was
parked on the pavement
and the hazard lights were were going
and
bus cctv and some other dash cam footage
showed that the doors were open and he
was standing with sarah at that time and
the hazard lights were on hazard lights
are on and can you deduce from the
footage whether they were talking
yes you can see that the two are engaged
in conversation
standing similar to where we are now in
conversation uh next to the car with the
doors open and he's not in uniform
well it's difficult to see from the
footage and and um but
i think what's clear
from the investigation that they
identified that he had used his
police authority whether he's police
badge
whether park uniform whatever he was
doing to effect that stop on sarah and
to make her stop
so what
do you know about what happened next
well from a witness i mean we've heard
that now that a witness uh saw sarah
being handcuffed
now for somebody to get into the back of
a car with a
essentially a stranger
albeit it might have a police badge
without doing anything wrong
it would take someone like sarah
probably not to get into that car she
probably wouldn't have gotten to the
back of that car the only reason that i
can think of in my experience as a
police officer is that he's had to get
her into that car somehow and the main
way to get her into that car is to put
under arrest and one of the witnesses
that has come forward in that inquiry
that they found
said that they saw sarah being
handcuffed and is there any evidence
that she put up a fight any kind of
struggle
not certainly that they've seen at that
point no um
essentially sarah's not the sort of
person if a police officer
arrested her
she could obviously be completely
confused and and quite alarmed and upset
like anybody would um but
certainly not the type of person that
would then fight a police officer to to
get away or anything that's not the type
of person she was from all the inquiries
uh made with their family and friends
the police investigation team identified
that she was a strong-willed character
um and
you know it wouldn't have really had
that effect on her she knew what was
going on that night
unfortunately she didn't know what what
was going on in that particular incident
what do you think cousins
might have said to her to convince her
that she was being rightfully arrested
well i don't know i mean he could have
made up a law he could have said
anything he wanted to to get her into
the car
i mean he could have used covid as a as
a reason to get her into the back of the
car and said you're breaching covered
rules and
arrested her you know sarah wouldn't
necessarily have known every single law
and he could have made one up to get her
in the back of the car i mean that that
has a ring of authenticity about it
yeah it does
whatever whatever it is and whatever he
said to her he's used deceit and
deception and
to get her into the back of that car for
the for the sole reason of
well abducting her
he was taking a huge chance doing what
he did on a brightly lit arterial road
with look you know dozens and dozens of
homes around us
people if they weren't out on the
streets were probably looking out of
their windows
why do you think he
chose this part
well i think then you have to go into
what kind of person he is
to take that chance i mean he hired
the car that he used to abduct sarah in
his own name
you know with his own address and his
own telephone number
so
being out in a road like this really
it just shows that that's a kind of
continuation of the kind of mindset that
he is
but he'd made certain preparations it
wasn't as though
this was a you don't think this was a
spur-of-the-moment thing for him
i don't think so and i don't think
anybody who works on that investigation
and
would think that this was
nothing other than pre-planned
premeditated this is part of him what he
wanted to do
he's hired a car he's gone he's driven
70 odd miles to come into central london
to abduct somebody
whether his intention was then to rape
them and kill them
he's admitted to that he's admitted to
all the facts that the police and the
cps have put in front of the court that
he abducted raped and murdered sarah so
i think that's what he set out to do
that night
chilling as it is um
what do you think happened or what do
you know happen next
well once
sarah's in the car there's obviously
that gap of
what's being said or what actually
happened
in terms of the route he's driven out of
london
the police investigation has used
ampr cameras
cctv his own telephone with his cell
site
information that's held on it
to put him all the way back into dover
obviously
sarah
what's happened to sarah in between
london
and dover
doesn't really bear thinking about i
mean he told a bizarre story
when you arrested him or just before you
arrested him yeah when officers went
into his house he's come up with this
really elaborate story that he was
involved with some european sex
traffickers or a prostitution gang and
they that he had
done something wrong and needed to
replace
a girl
and that's reason why he was getting
somebody off the street to give to this
gang
that's and that's the thing he said when
the officers were standing next to him
in his house i mean it sounds crazy but
you couldn't ignore that could you
police investigations can't ignore
things like that you know
we've all been involved in the most
bizarre
bizarre of investigations where
you think the story is not true but it
turns out to be true so you have to an
investigation team that that dealt with
this investigation would have gone
meticulously through cctv footage from
here to dover to see if that car stopped
if he was met by anybody else whether he
was with anybody else and obviously they
found that nobody else was involved in
this at all it was just him
his idea that what he wanted to do when
he left his dover house to come here to
abduct somebody
and sarah was unfortunately his target
that night
how quickly did you identify cousins
well the the investigation
was waiting for
cctv footage we didn't know if it would
hold anything but when buses move up and
down roads they have cameras at the
front so you wait for that footage to be
down it's not a quick thing so in
between that time you try and identify
any other cctv cameras that might help
you would look at
people
that
were seen on those cameras to see where
they went
but obviously the investigation team
didn't see sarah past this point
so there is something has happened uh
here
and it could have been that she turned
off and gone down a back alley or
something like that but that's that
again that was
you know ruled out quite quickly so it
was the point that the cctv camera from
the bus identifies the car
and then with other cctv you can see the
number plate the number plate comes back
to this car a higher car from dover
immediate inquiries into there as you
can imagine as fast as possible
identify that wayne cousins has hired
that car
and then the next stage is who is wayne
cousins himself
and you quickly found the answer yeah
and it was
you know it's one of those things and i
i know
in the sio
and all that team and everybody that
worked on it and all the different
um people that came together when they
found out that it was a police officer
um it was something that would stay with
me certainly
before i left the met that stayed me for
the rest of my life and i think
it upset a lot of officers
as you can imagine and um
and it's terrible
publicity isn't it i mean the
the perception of the public
that a police officer could be
responsible for this you know this
authority figure i mean you tell me in
your words that how the public generally
view
cops i think do you know what
heartbreaking is what it was to start
with to start with because you know the
policing is is not an easy job as we all
know and
you know we get bashed up a lot by the
media
and i think that
when those officers realize that it was
a police officer
you know some of those things that you
you have in common practice in your in
your family lives come into play when
you tell your children
or you tell as a friend or whatever you
know if you're in trouble
try and find a police officer well that
what he did that day
has set that back
to such a distance behind us that we've
you know you try and recover and you try
and
say we're not like that you know there
are thousands of police officers working
this country who
sent in messages of support to say to
the family we're not like that that's
not what we are about
and
you know that was a real it's a really
important message i think to say that
yes it's difficult to understand police
officers you know and i've i've now
recently retired but police officers do
not view wayne cousins as a police
officer
they view him as a murderer
who happens to be a police officer
rather than the other way around a
police officer who is a murderer and
it's a really important thing you know
he doesn't hold the same values as a
police officer he doesn't have the same
personality that we do you know he's a
very sick
and very dangerous individual who should
never have been near a uniform
can you tell me a bit about having
identified him there was still an awful
lot of work to do
wasn't there
because he wasn't initially admitting
anything
yes i mean
he did say those few things about the
eastern european scenario yeah and then
moving on from that
when he's interviewed by
the investigation team he doesn't say
anything just says no comment and he's
never offered an explanation
from
that point to now
even a conviction never
even at sentencing has never said
anything about it so there are still
lots of unanswered questions about what
happened where was sarah murdered as one
of those questions it would be
it would be such a thing that the family
would want to hear
to know the full story about what
happened and there will be some
obviously horrendous details in it but
there's so many elements of this case
which
the police still don't know
you know where did it happen what did he
exactly do but we do know then that he's
taken sarah and
probably killed her between then and
returning the higher car at 8 30 the
next morning into dover
he's had to transfer her body into his
own car at some stage as well because
then he takes his own car to hodes woods
in ashford and kent
where
he takes her body and
probably keeps it under
what i believe was a fridge freezer at
the time
and is then going on to buy rubble saxon
shops order things on the internet and
leaving a trail leaving a trail all the
time using his own
credit cards or you know his own finance
to
to do that using his own accounts to buy
things on the internet
and then
really sadly obviously he finishes by
setting fire to
uh the body of sarah and um then he
would transfer that into sax
into um
a big rubble uh big builders sack
and then she was deposited in a um
a kind of water area within hose woods
um
i know that you can't answer precisely
this but can you put yourself in
sarah's position she's been arrested
she's in the back of the police car
she's handcuffed
and presumably
because there's no evidence of a fight
initially
she may be thinking well okay perhaps
there is a legitimate reason perhaps i
shouldn't have been out but as the car
travels through south london
what do you think might have been going
through her mind well i think this is
something that a lot of people have
talked about
you know at what stage
would sarah have realized something was
wrong
he might have asked her to turn her
phone off
um
it could have done something like that
you know which would have been normal
please practice you know turn your phone
off or give it to me you can't have it
as a as a prisoner at the time um and
then he has gone to
driven out of london and i think at that
point sarah must have been thinking
what's going on here you know quite
often in in policing
sales in london became full up become
full up so you're not necessarily you
might not necessarily go to the closest
police station so there you are arrested
they may have passed a police station
and he might have said that we're going
to go to the next one or i work at this
one or this is where we deal with this
type of prisoner he could have said
anything so that to stop her from
um panicking or or realizing that
something was wrong but i think it's got
to be got to be at some stage when she's
realized
wait a minute where are we going you
know he's heading towards dover so
there's got to be something happening
between
london and dover where
and her feeling completely powerless
yes i mean being handcuffed obviously as
we know is
you know it is restrictive for a reason
right and so i think
it doesn't really bear thinking about
that she's you know she's powerless to
know what happens next
um and it's really sad to think
that she's that quite scary situation
that she's in at that point
this case does throw up and puts a focus
on
the vetting of police officers
it's not as simple as the public might
think is it
no i mean
officers have to go through different
levels of vetting depending on what they
become involved in within policing the
first vetting is to become a police
officer in the first place and then you
might go into other different
departments where the vetting is higher
but there isn't a huge department of
people doing this you know when you are
talking potentially about things like
twenty thousand officers joining
policing you know six thousand of those
are directed towards the met police
which is what we're going through now
yes the recruitment so when you when you
bring in
uh
vast levels of recruitment and quickly
as well
then
you have to have a system behind that
which supports that level of vetting
so
perhaps in some cases
it's not as watertight as it should be
and cousins wasn't somebody with any
criminal convictions i mean there may
have been suspicions about him but
you know obviously if somebody's got
criminal convictions that's one thing
but having you know maybe odd behavior
it's very difficult to use that to
preclude somebody from
doing what you know for most cops as a
pretty grim job yes i know his level of
vetting would have been high as well
because of his use of a firearm he's
come from another form of policing
not the standard policing that you think
a police officer goes through he's not
walked the streets of london and worn a
uniform and talked to members of the
public and run after criminals or dealt
with prisoners in custody he's not done
that sort of thing
you know and so so he's come to this
this kind of policing that he was doing
and he's carrying a gun so his level of
vetting would have been quite high and
it would have been done properly
if you talk to his uh friends you know
the investigation talked to colleagues
and friends as you can imagine nobody
saw this that's a really important point
nobody saw this nobody would raise the
red flag nobody at work
uh raised the red flag for him you know
yes he was off sick with stress but that
was quite you know in the few days that
he that he had told his supervisors but
he's not he's not somebody that would
stand out as a as an oddball or
something you would think right we need
to we need to stop what he's doing and
you know so
there's a difference isn't there there's
a difference between vetting
20 000 people and that sort of thing and
getting that right all the time and
mistakes
aren't necessarily mistakes they're just
things that you can't see and i didn't
ask you about his phone he tell me what
happened with his phone yeah
so at the time that
officers went through
wayne cousins front door to arrest him
what had been discovered later on was
that wayne cousins had wiped his phone
clean
minutes before he was arrested
but does it do him any good well
potentially he might have got rid of
some stuff that we would never see
but
what is does remain is your cell site
which is your telephone and call data
so that was able to we were able to use
that
at the time to track him in london and
out to kent and then all of his
movements around the wood
where
he eventually deposited sarah's body
[Music]